It's all right you guys.
It's 4 degrees at the airport
right now and we're seeing
mainly cloudy skies.
We saw some nice breaks of
sunshine this morning but
generally through the day,
cloudy skies and the sun was
able to filtre its way through,
so that was nice.
It was a fairly pleasant day
warming up to 7 degrees which
is our average.
That's right where we should be
sort of for this time of year.
Now when we look at the pattern
we still have that high pressure
in place, mild conditions across
our area, and it's fairly
stagnant across the south.
Meanwhile, the North Coast
getting hammered by two
different systems, one really
affecting their region tonight.
There's a wind warning in place.
Southeast winds up to 90 kilometers
an hour expected.
I'm already seeing reports at
about 66-70 kilometers an hour in
Prince Rupert.
But the jet stream is driving
way up into northern regions and
we're going to see that pattern
continue into our Saturday and
that's really going to bring in
the milder air across northern
parts of the province.
Some areas will be 20 degrees
above average in the coming
days.
Here's a look at the RE/MAX
satellite.
We have some cloud cover
Just off the coast, though,
few showers starting to
push in.
So tonight, for the lower
mainland South Coast, a slight
chance of showers.
We'll see that early tomorrow
morning but generally tomorrow
back to mainly cloudy skies as
these systems really just funnel
towards the North Coast.
So wet and windy across the
North Coast, snow for inland
regions in the morning and by
the afternoon hours that spreads
all the way down into areas like
Prince George and over towards
Valemount, a real finger of
precipitation pushing in there.
Meanwhile, the South Coast
we'll see, be split in half.
Northern regions from about
Sechelt north have the chance
of showers and then basically
Comox north across Vancouver
Island, the chance of
precipitation, dryer conditions
further south.
And if you're in Whistler you do
have a chance of flurries as
well towards the afternoon
hours.
So here's your forecast, as I
mentioned, wet and windy across
the North Coast, even inland
regions.
Smithers, though, I'm expecting
snow for you, it's colder,
about 5 centimeters.
Flurries by the afternoon in
Prince George and down towards
Quesnel, and then over to
Valemount.
Meanwhile, areas further south,
mainly cloudy.
Same plan that you've seen in
the last couple of days and
you'll see that not only
tomorrow but on Saturday as
well.
South Coast as well, this is
your plan for tomorrow, the rain
across northern regions,
mostly dry across the south.
Slight chance of showers but
that's about it.
And we're hoping for a sunny
breaks not only on Friday but
into our Saturday as well.
We don't see a change until
Sunday and it's a brief period
of rain.
And otherwise, we're back to
sunshine on Monday.
Happy birthday to Ida Kowalsky.
She turned 101.
Winn Blake turned 100.
Congratulations to you both and
a happy anniversary to
Anne and Al Hersh,
they celebrate their 70th
tonight.
Congratulations.
And our weather window for
tonight is a really neat shot
from the Northwest Territories
from John, which is a sundog
and I will put an explanation
of how that is made on our
Facebook page.